Colten seems like you are attracted to
drama you seem to go for women you fight
with do you think that's something you
need to work on yep
I definitely agree with that I think
part of the drama the fire passage
something back and honestly think like
dating American girls grow up down the
street is not even something I can do at
this point I feel like I need that extra
level of excitement it's like a drug at
this point you need you just you just
compared it to a drug addiction cause
yeah not good no Debbie who do you think
is more trustworthy or more more of a
good person if you had to choose Jess or
Larissa oh man I would choose arista
really yeah I know but yeah why is that
because there is evil but she's honesty
I'm not gonna lie trust
Larissa because I can I know her and
spend more time with her yeah and I know
what she's about I got justice total
mystery to me it sounds like you think
jess is more dishonest yes yes we also
have seen Larissa warning Jess about you
Debbie how did you feel when you saw
that yeah she claiming that Colton are
dead to her but she keeps bringing this
up and she keeps interfering with his
life apparently so
yeah for being dead to her we also we
could mention a lot she must have a
Ouija board or something yeah oh yeah
well the last time I talked to you guys
which was several weeks ago at this
point but you were you seem to be in a
little bit of a better place with her
you seemed not getting along well but
you know at least sort of neutral and
and maybe just staying away from things
but
this season airing brought things up
again have you spoken to Larissa at all
I haven't spoken with Larissa at all
since literally the day she left this
house long time ago and no I I still
feel neutral towards Larissa I don't
have any yeah anything bad against her I
just feel like she has a lot of problems
with me a lot and I don't know why
exactly and we never really had that
resolution but at this point yeah
is there anything you would want to hear
from her at this point after seeing some
of the things she said this season no I
mean she can say whatever she wanted to
say about me and she has her own
opinions of course and I don't think
there's anything she could say to me
that would make me feel happy or sad or
anything I wish there was I wish I could
say stuff to her and make her feel
better but at this point I don't feel
like there's any words that could
satisfy any of us Colt you had kind of
hinted that viewers might not recognize
Larissa and I'll be honest with you I I
do think she looks fairly different um
so I was just wondering if you knew
anything about anything she had done and
what you thought of it I I didn't know I
mean I I watched the episode of like you
did we she listed off all the things she
changed like that's a lot yeah when I
was married to her she unless she wanted
I think was like a breast augmentation
and her lips but she went through that
list like she's more plastic now that
woman honestly at this point I don't
understand it but
yeah I'm looking forward to seeing well
she's gonna do this season honestly but
she I don't I don't know the extent or
to what degree she has planned for
herself
I just hope by then she's really happy
with everything she's done to herself
where she isn't lying do you think she's
capable of being happy about it it's not
for me to say I really wish that be
saying no I think Larissa needs to be
happy with her inner stuff and I think
she had a lot of work to do on that I
really hope she finds whatever she
that's only that really want what
happens when her parts
he watched euphoria I watch it I like
you I actually probably watch it most
intensely about all of them because it's
weird because she was my wife but she's
also kind of attached to me on this show
together you know so but I haven't
talked with her since she left like a
year your Africa that's like I'm getting
updates in a weird way I don't know it's
like I like to I like where it all be
the rest behind me at the same time it's
like it's ongoing still yeah so let me
tell you so why do you watch so
intensely what are you searching for I
don't know if I'm searching for anything
in particular it's just because I'm so
attached to it I know more about I don't
know anything about all the other
couples in any personal way yeah that's
a good point also and honestly then did
I want her to be happy yeah I'm kind of
I'm rooting for honestly and I don't buy
the engine is happy Debbie what do you
feel Colt needs in his life what kind of
woman do you want to see him with and do
you think he should continue dating
women abroad I want him to find a woman
that is truly in love with him and he
isn't truly in love with them but I
wanted to be a relationship that they
can count on each other be there for
each other like each other communicate
with each other and so far he hasn't had
that you do not think he has that with
Jess no not just the Portuguese in
English no it's not that kind of
communication it's a communication of on
you've built I was 37 years old when I
met your dad your dad was 40 years old
we had that communication we were
married for 20 years
26 years but it took me a long time to
find this person so it's a connection
you make and you you spend every day
together and you build this relationship
it's not just sex it's not just whatever
it's a bond that you can't break it's
love it's something you you work at well
sex has been brought up a lot on this
season with you and Jess
to be I'm just gonna ask you do you
think colt is too much focused on the
sexual attraction his relationships
actually I think Jess was more talking
about sex than you were she was talking
about it when you were at their house so
I think that it's an important part but
I don't think you should jump into it
right away
colt what do you think have you looked
at attraction too much instead of
communication like mom saying oh yeah I
feel pretty grill I'll be like Hello I
mean if I can say hello even I mean at
that point it doesn't even matter yeah I
definitely I do feel like I've always
been you know easily you are attracted
to people we know if I see a pretty girl
at stuff something that isn't weakness
for me well I gotta tell you I feel like
we're working through a lot right now
you know what your issues are mom knows
what your issues are you just got a bike
the bullet on you'll be asked them let
me tell you you know a lot has happened
laws going on in my life and I think
you're right and that's something that's
great about this season there's a lot of
that actually it goes in really
interesting directions and you're gonna
find out first thing I started with it's
not cool we also might see more of
Vanessa what do you want to clear up
about what's happening with that
connection
oh Vanessa Vanessa is a good friend of
mine I met her you know when I was still
married to Larissa she's just a friend
and then after my divorce became better
friends and we became more than friends
but not really a relationship and now
we're just we're friends I always been
really good friends
honestly they friends more have I told
you about the friends oh but Vanessa and
I I feel like Vanessa are just really
kind of kindred spirits we're friends
but always there's some of your life you
can always count on to be there for
anything but we'll see I don't know
right now I'm really just
wanna see what's gonna happen yeah
everything else Debbie do you like
Vanessa absolutely definitely good match
for cold I think so
I think so but they're really good
friends and maybe eventually I think you
need to be friends and a solid
relationship so who knows never know
okay all right well cool what can you
tease for us about where you're at right
now are you happy right now
unhappy what's your status I'm happy
right now let me tell you I I feel like
I've gone through a lot since specially
quarantine and everything you know lost
some weight just trying to figure myself
out
all right now are you I think last time
we talked you'd said you'd you'd lost
your job where are you at with that in
quarantine I'm still unemployed
everybody it is yeah let me tell you I'm
very a lot of a lot large amounts of
uncertainty for to be sure and I don't
know where my future will go or what I
will be doing but even though I don't
know anything I'm starting to figure out
who I am and I'm okay with that
[Music]